all right I'm just gonna get straight to
it so when you assume you make an error
out of you and me I thought this was a
really catchy top title you know it's a
play on words on a play on words about
the pitfalls of assumptions which is
what I wanted to talk about how we can
communicate wrongly when we assume so
it's a great title right Rico but it
turns out that it's actually really not
it's a really bad title because what
I've done is I've assumed that everybody
listening to me speak and reading this
title is one familiar with English to a
high degree we're talking first language
levels here and too familiar with
informal English phrases such as when
you assume you make an ass out of you
and me this is the phrase guys in case
you didn't know it but I'm really sorry
I assumed that you knew so let's just
move on from that unfortunately there is
a positive twist to this because it's a
great example of what I'm here to ask
you to try and be aware of so let's
agree that anything I say from here on
out can and most definitely will be
applied to myself there's a small caveat
there these little asterisks that will
show up when there is a flashing visual
on the following slide just as a trigger
warning so I'm Gabby I work at the
Financial Times we are the world's
leading news organization and Business
and Economic Affairs I've been there for
a couple of years now and I've been very
lucky to work in a company that values
its culture very strongly because it
means that the people that work there
care about the people that work there
and it's a great environment to learn
and develop in so I work specifically on
a team called origami we are the FTS
component library and essentially our
work is geared at simplifying other
people's work and we try to be as
accessible as possible in every sense of
the word because our
users are developers but developers from
various different backgrounds developing
various different ft products for
various different ft customers so that
means that we need to make our
components as clear as possible in their
functionality and their documentation
one of the ways in which we do this is
by maintaining a public registry
it houses information on all of the
components that we own and develop and
it provides demos to assist others in
their implementation earlier this year
we rewrote and redesigned this registry
you want to make it fast and sleek and
cool to use and stuff and on the day
that we launched it we got a cake to
celebrate with our users unfortunately I
didn't get a picture of the cake when it
was whole because it was a good cake but
I figured I would use that opportunity
to get some feedback from our users on
our registry and I wrote on the cake box
right so I wrote for cake slice please
to leave nice feedback on post-it note
and I thought I was being really
charming and like I'd got my point
across and we got feedback but all of
our feedback was on the cake
so it's amusing to see people compliment
cake for sure they get creative but
because I made an assumption about what
people knew I didn't get the feedback
that I had asked for it so we have been
working on the registry for a while and
because of that we knew why there was
cake everybody else just saw you know
delicious chocolatey and free cake and
that really complicates things for us
because what I really want to highlight
is that it's very easy to forget that we
don't know what others know and that
others don't know what we know and at
one point or another we all make
assumptions that we believe to be an
offensive and because of what we don't
know these assumptions can be harmful to
our interactions so I'm going to talk
about a few aspects of our industry
where we may frequently make assumptions
starting with error message it's mm-hmm
so I'll venture it guess that nobody
really wants to see error messages but
at one point or another we all need them
and we may even secretly be grateful for
them when they make sense so when they
do make sense they have the ability to
help us improve our code and learn from
the mistakes that we make when they
don't make sense
maybe one of two things can happen one
we've seen the error or the type before
and we can have a guess at what went
wrong and the odds are that this is
going to sink a potentially unnecessary
amount of time into debugging the issue
because we didn't have the relevant
information from the start or we don't
understand the error and the wording
makes us feel bad about something that
we've done just gonna be this there for
a second
so we can feel like we don't know how
the language works and we can possibly
feel embarrassed that we don't
understand the error or what we've done
wrong both of which do nothing for our
drive to improve and learn and it can be
detrimental to our belief in our
capability so I've asked Donnie so let
me share their tweet because I was
immediately struck by it when I first
read it and it says as tool builders
we're gatekeepers every time we print an
incomprehensible error message someone
decides they're not good enough at
coding and even though I've been working
in this industry for a few years I come
across error messages pretty frequently
that make me feel like I have no idea
what I'm doing and they make my faith
and what I think I understand pretty
wobbly so today I want to focus on point
number two when error messages make us
feel bad I want to highlight what I
think are some of the problems in the
way that error messages are communicated
and I've picked a few examples to
illustrate my point so try to consider
what I'm saying as a blanket statement
for error messages you might have seen
out in the wild so let's begin type
error undefined is not a function
problem we've got here is ambiguity to
one extent or another all of the error
messages that I'm going to show you are
ambiguous they aren't specific about
what has gone wrong and this wording
implies that we know where to start if
we see this error and while this might
be true for some we could all just be
helped along if we knew what the context
was the message here is being ambiguous
by not telling us what the air were
undefined is referencing and little
caveat to be fair most bravura browsers
have implemented a referencing system
but this doesn't detract from the fact
that this still applies to other error
messages uncaught error object object
yay so big problem that we have here is
succinct Ness in most cases unhelpful
error messages
our short perhaps their short and to the
point for some but it's entirely
possible that the point is completely
missed by others and I don't mean we
need to write a novel about the details
of the error message but a sentence or
two could help shed a lot of light onto
the problem whatever the real error is
here it's been shrunk down to two
generally unhelpful words and finally
unexpected token comma expected comma
guys this doesn't even look like a real
sentence but big problem we have here is
obfuscation this is on par with
ambiguity the specifics of what has gone
wrong are hidden away somewhere so
useful information is being withheld and
this is gonna add a complication from
the start in this example logically a
comma is a comma so something else must
have gone wrong I just don't have the
information to know what that is or how
to deal with it so let me reiterate what
I'm saying by creating an imaginary
scenario for you okay picture yourself
at the entrance of a hedge maze in
daylight there are no threats in this
maze and your objective is to get to the
center of it when you get lost a
mystical Boulder will materialize with
directions on it so you step into the
maze and after a few right turns and a
few wrong turns you come to a fork but
you find that you've lost your sense of
direction boom magical Boulder has a
sentence on it and that sentence says
turn north
and so this is how I feel when I deal
with an error message that I don't
understand so next time we write error
messages let's try to keep these things
in mind context to counter ambiguity
have we provided a connection between
the problem and what is causing it
elaboration to counter what was it that
I said it's a sickness
sorry good are we being sufficiently
verbose have we provided relevant
details about the problem and finally
clarity to counter obfuscation overall
is our message clear have we surfaced
all of the things that are important
about the error in our explanation of it
I've raised these points to aid us in
moving away from general assumptions
that we can make about what our users
understand and this will allow our
wording to be as inclusive as possible
but these points also apply to our
documentation which brings me to the
read me read knees are pretty crucial to
our projects they're often the single
source of documentation that a user will
come across so what we say and how we
choose to convey it is very important I
know I bragged about my company a little
bit at the beginning but it's mostly so
that I can point out that we also make
these mistakes and take for example this
readme
it belongs to a public repository that
the FT owns and this is it there's
nothing more to it I want everyone to
focus on this bit of it I have so many
questions so what is this library what's
wrong with installing it globally what
package manager a moment to use what is
n B T or n bt5 for that matter and why
does it get its own patches so who is
this even for and first off
just because I work there when I know
this this read me assumes that everyone
knows where the library should be used
no context it gives you a warning about
installation but no installation
instructions so there's no elaboration
and ultimately there's no explicit
explanation for what this library
actually does so there's no clarity
either and the fact is that this whole
project assumes that you work for the FT
it assumes that you know what our
workflow is like it assumes that you
know what our tools are and is done
really unhelpful but while all of that
may be true for the people that already
work there it's just not helpful helpful
for someone that may have just joined
for example but after raising all of
this in-house we've changed it so if you
guys go looking for it it's not gonna
look like this anymore we've specified
what this project is used for and we've
provided further information for anyone
that might need it or might want it and
not only were installation instructions
vague there were two years out of date
so we've elaborated and provided and
explicit installation commands and we've
provided clarity so we've emitted
abbreviations and there's more
information
overall we've been more explicit about
the functionality of this project so we
facilitator other people's use of it I'm
aware that there's a lot more that we
should add to this readme but I don't
have time and it doesn't fit on one side
so even if we don't have time to go
through everything right now remembering
to supply context elaborate where
relevant and provide clarity will help
us improve the way in which we write but
writing isn't the only way in which we
communicate in this industry we talk a
lot to exhibit a
so in addition to what we've covered so
far
the next equally important point to
consider is who is your audience and I
can't stress this enough whom are we
speaking to and who are we writing for
everybody in this audience exists in a
different spectrum of experience and
understanding so when we talk to someone
from our version of the spectrum we talk
through the filters of our own
experience and this is really important
to be aware of these are our own
experiences and conversely when we talk
to somebody else we're talking to
somebody that has a spectrum all of
their own and that is made up of their
experiences so if we want to have a good
exchange we need to find common ground
together instead of assuming there is
common ground and we probably don't
intend it badly when we assume someone
else will know what we're talking about
and hey maybe they do but we could be
clear from the beginning and there are a
few things that we can do to improve our
communication firstly we can start by
acknowledging that we do make
assumptions at one point or another this
means that we can begin to notice the
things that we can improve second when
we are talking about something we should
work to elaborate without judgment it
takes practice absolutely but it's
important to learn not to assume that
the person you are speaking to knows
what you were talking about and thereby
provide more information that was loud
sorry
so I have found myself explaining to
something to someone in a way that makes
perfect sense to me until I look up and
I see the person looking a little bit
like this and I've had that look on my
face a few times as well
and usually it's because I didn't get
that extra bit of elaboration I didn't
understand the context I may have missed
the Darden perhaps I just didn't know
what they were saying but just
elaborating isn't enough we need to pay
attention to how we say what we say we
understand the world through the words
we use through the words we hear and
through the words that we read so
consider that very carefully in this
case it doesn't matter who you talk to
but the words that you choose to speak
with are far from inconsequential and
this brings me to a few examples of
language that we can learn to avoid as
outlined in the Code of Conduct for this
conference commentary like you would be
crazy to think you would have to be
blind not to notice is a list
it's ablest and it's alienating if you
do think in a particular way or if you
don't notice something whether or not
you have a disability and it's degrading
language so please leave this out words
and phrasing like all you need to do
just obviously clearly simply they
trivialize what may not be obvious or
clear to someone else and they're filler
words and we can omit these too and
finally everyone knows or any developer
worth their salt
there are examples of career
generalizations that can be exclusionary
we've already covered the fact that we
don't know what others know and setting
arbitrary benchmarks for someone's
knowledge or worth is just destructive
so let's not use these either make sure
that you give your interactions your
full attention with that we can start
picking up on the things that we say we
may use some of the language that I just
talked about unconsciously and in fact I
know that I do I probably just said just
somewhere like there it happens but the
beauty of interacting with somebody else
is that we can ask questions so do ask
ask questions about the content of your
conversations and provide your listeners
with the opportunity to correct you
where you may not notice that you might
have made a mistake and when we do ask
those questions and provide that chance
there's benefit in it for us as well we
can take that opportunity to learn about
what our assumptions were in that
scenario and begin to correct ourselves
when we notice that our language might
have slipped
so with these points and lines we can go
into our conversations with more
awareness make them more productive more
effective and more inclusive I need to
let this slide because it's a good gift
so I'd like to stress that this is a
learning process and it takes practice
and we will probably make mistakes
throughout that process but it also
doesn't cost you anything to practice
and you lose nothing by making the
effort unlike this cat so if we practice
acknowledging our assumptions
elaborating without judgment asking
questions and paying attention to the
words that we use will benefit from
richer and more constructive
interactions going forward I am
definitely pouring a lot of energy into
pointing out assumptions an overall
implying that they have negative effects
and while this is true it is also true
to a large extent that assumptions are
simplifications that make life possible
for example if we're walking along a
sidewalk we do so relatively confidently
because we assume that the drivers
aren't gonna drive up in front of us and
the drivers drive confidently assuming
that people aren't gonna leap out in
front of a street in front of them
helpful so if we had to double check
with every driver going by that that was
the case nobody would ever get anywhere
and it would be equally unrealistic to
try and have an answer for every
possible situation that we find
ourselves assuming in which really begs
the question once you start where do you
stop the correct answer that everybody
really wants to know is that there is no
correct answer ultimately we don't have
the brain power or the time to come up
with a solution to every scenario but we
can lay the foundations in the word
choices that we make for our errors for
our documentation and our speech which
can cover a lot of ground where we can't
cover every eventuality which
for the last time brings me back to we
don't know what others know and others
don't know what we know
so in all types of communication let us
strive to provide context to elaborate
freely to convey clarity to be aware of
the words that we communicate with and
to ask so that we can learn and apply
what we learned to ourselves with that
will be setting ourselves up for better
interactions and will already be at a
huge advantage finally I would like to
leave you with a quote by American
novelist Ursula Guin which I might have
browsed incorrectly words transform both
speaker and hearer they feed energy back
and forth and amplify it
they feed understanding or emotion back
and forth and amplify it so remember the
goal is not to make an ass out of anyone
so thank you for listening to me